i think what happened in my life was i
experienced the spread
and the evolution of the world wide web
and
and i and i saw it unfold in front of my
in front of my own eyes and
i was completely fascinated by it
welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders we're welcomed today with max or
faga
founder of minimize the brand helping
retail investors become smarter
investors
through bite-sized jargon free expert
content
finimize is the world's largest and most
engaged finance community with over 1
million users
before finimize co max co-founded an
e-commerce startup with 200 employees
and sold it in 2015.
he also mentors a tech stars and started
bootcamp and was named one of forbes 30
under 30.
max verfaga welcome to 20 minute leaders
from switzerland how are you doing my
friend
i'm very good how are you i'm doing
great thank you for joining me here
today
um max you have an interesting story and
i'm excited to tell it
it's a story uh based on
entrepreneurship
it's starting from creating a website
that showcases bart simpson jokes
but it continues to e-commerce with 200
employees i believe what what the hell
and then
and then it it now is with finimize
uh looking at retail investors with
bite-sized content
before we dive into these separate
stories
who is max if you look at yourself now
in switzerland
who who are you in in essence
uh this is a very deep question oh yeah
um we get deep here in the show
yeah i love it so i mean i think at the
end of the day
uh um i i
i i would like to think of myself as a
as an independent
person i i really value independence um
and i love to
engage in projects uh that require
both sides of your brain so they require
you to be
analytical and creative and
that's what gives me a lot of joy and
and i think
in order to do that be independent
and use both sides of your brain digital
products are the fantastic playground
for that
so that's why what i've been doing
pretty much all of my career
and it sounds like you've been doing it
before your career already back in
school
um yeah walk me through some of the
biggest projects and
and what you've learned so even even
starting back from from the website in
school with bart
simpson how did that even begin and and
looking back at it
what what what did it mean for you
yeah so i think when i think back
basically like
i i got very early exposure uh to
computers
um so my dad was always uh
very very um i guess progressive
he would get he he like had a laptop
back in the day and the laptop was the
size of a suitcase wow
and it had like uh dos on it um
and like a tiny tiny screen and like
this massive machine behind it
and so i think i've like always had this
early on exposure to computers
and i think what happened in my life
was i experienced
the spread and the evolution
of the world wide web and and i saw it
unfold in front of my in front of my own
eyes and
i was completely fascinated by it um i
remember very vividly
when my parents got internet connection
at their house
um and i remember um
how fascinated i was to see like
websites from
all over the world um and how it works
etc
um and that then i think really sparked
this interest in this curiosity in this
whole like online world
and i just started to lean into that
curiosity and i
started to look at how can i build my
own website
and i started to look at how can you
make your website look really cool and
so back in the day you
i don't know if you remember but like
everybody had like flash
videos on their website and like that
was the fancy thing
and so i started doing a little bit of
flash videos um
and it was really just all about like
can i build
something out of my bedroom back then
uh that the world can see and i got like
really
excited about that idea that i can like
put a website up and then
back in the day that was like hosted on
geocities.com for those of you who
remember
and um i mean the thing that i kind of
struggled with was like
what do i actually put on my website
because i was a kid i didn't really have
that much to tell you
and that's what then one day i you know
it's kind of like sitting at my desk and
i had this book like that was the entire
book was just part simpson jokes and so
i was like yeah you know what
i'm just gonna start typing up these
bart simpson jokes and that's the
content from my website
um and that's how that started amazing
and uh
and obviously you know since then you
know like today
my technical skills are completely out
of date um
but uh that's how it started yeah it's
uh it's it's it's
really that like what i always say is
like
i'm part of the generation i'm part of
i'm
part of the last generation that knows
life
consciously before the world wide web
before people had smartphones
um and and and and that really thought
for me was
was i think a very very crucial
experience
yeah i a lot of times i feel like i i
missed out because i think i was born
two years too late to be with that to be
to be with that generation because i
i i had a smartphone i believe already
in eighth grade and i don't think i
understood
life at that point and so i wish
i kind of wish i had another couple
years to experience you know real
the real world and the real human
interaction that are not based on
what's happening in the digital world
but from there
you know where it doesn't stop at bart
simpson jokes you go and you build
an e-commerce startup with with 200
employees
and which also which also gets acquired
in 2015
is there a passion for e-commerce that
leads you there what did it even do why
why start that
so what happened was basically i i i
studied
um economics and international relations
because i was always interested in in
these topics
and when you do that and you're
at a college or university all of these
like
big corporations come to the careers
fairs are like you need to go
work for this consulting firm or this
banking firm or whatever
and nobody was like oh you should join
the startup you know
and so i i did that for
like for a year i worked in a consulting
firm um
and the funny thing was that i actually
tried to
create a startup i i try to
poach one of the managing directors and
do a spin-off
uh where we would start our own
consulting firm but i realized very
quickly that
i don't really i'm not very passionate
about consulting wow i was more
passionate about
like actually creating stuff and um
and then i had some like friends um who
i've been like
tinkering with on products and like
we've been like brainstorming around
ideas and and they basically one day
we're like hey you know why don't we
start a an e-commerce business and
uh that was in the day when like daily
deals were like
the hot you know and uh and so we
started that
uh with the daily deal model and then we
very quickly expanded it
into full-on e-commerce with like a
warehouse and everything
wow um and how old are you at that point
i was like 24 wow
um so that was that was crazy experience
because obviously like you know
at age 24 i didn't know anything um
and i learned everything by doing right
like i've
i have zero background in retail i and
to answer your question i also had like
no real passion about retail um if
anything i thought it was a bit boring
wow um maybe that's what i wanted what
exactly but but i also was fascinated by
and really excited actually about like
the idea of of building a company
uh and and building a company uh that
reaches a lot of people
um and and that's what that's i think
where the excitement came from um
and and we did that and that grew super
quickly and was really really
fun and a lot of work um
and and now with fitmize it's like you
know it's a real passion project for me
um
but again i also never thought i would
get into finance or i would get into
like
the media world you know a lot of this i
always try to like
go with the flow right and i think then
a lot of opportunities open up if you go
with the flow
so so walk me through finimize and and
some of the thinking
behind that you have more than you have
more than a million users
and you know when you're talking about a
finance community and
what does that actually mean and how
what is the pain point that you're
observing
that finimize is coming to solve
so i'm sure everybody by now has
been following what's been happening in
the retail investment space
right where uh more retail investors
than ever have entered the market
and and that is because the barriers to
entry have been radically
lowered so commission free trading
fractional shares you can now buy not an
amazon share cost thousands of dollars
you can buy
part of it for 100 all of these things
helped
the normal retail investor enter the
market and so last year in the u.s alone
10 million new retail investors entered
the market
um and then in q1 all of the major
brokers are reporting that they grew
faster than all of 2020.
wow so there's this like massive
acceleration happening
and so there's a lot of talk about
democratizing financial markets
and i think the thing that we're now
starting to see is that
in order to democratize financial
markets it's it's not just about the
infrastructure that we just talked about
it's also about where do people
get their information yeah and what
happens today is
that all of the existing financial
information
outlets are super expensive and
if you want to put down them that amount
of money are really difficult
to to keep up to date with and to wrap
your head around
and that's created the vacuum and so
people have been turning to free sources
like tick-tock you have all these like
sudo finance gurus on tick tock
um and who are trying to tell you this
is the next
altcoin and uh and put all of your money
on this et cetera
um and then you have obviously the rise
of reddit et cetera
and and our belief is that while there's
still a lot of interesting stuff there
but that is trying that that there's a
vacuum there where people are
looking for high quality investing
information that they can turn to and
that they can trust
you know trust is so important in
finance
and we with finimize are trying to
fill that vacuum an affordable high
quality
and finance portal that
caters to the modern investor and the
modern investor
has three attributes that we
cater to with our product number one
they learn by doing
so that's why they for example do a lot
of fractional shares
number two they're very time poor so
everything we do is bite-sized
and number three they are very community
driven
now so over 90 percent report that when
they make an investment decision
they consult their peers yeah and so
and that's why we're very community true
um and that's what really
the way we think about it we're a modern
financial information platform and
community
i i mean that that's very interesting i
can think through some friends that you
know whatever they purchase or sell
you know it becomes the topic of
conversation and and i think one of the
things that we're all feeling is that
but we're talking about it but we're
lacking some important information
and and yeah we don't want to go and now
explore and understand everything about
this market and about this company but
but if we had you know snippets of
information that that
enabled us to to elevate the
conversation a little bit
uh that's uh that that is definitely
something that could be very
uh that could be very very meaningful
yeah and so now you're with finimize you
have a million users
where do you see it where do you see it
grow where do you see it progress
it's i believe four or five years old
where where is both you know the
the retail investment the retail
investors market
heading and where is finima is heading
alongside that
and so i think that this modern retail
investor is here to stay
and so i think you're going to start to
see a lot more products that cater to
these three attributes that i just
mentioned
and we're obviously want to be continue
to be at the forefront of that
and the way that we really want to
develop
is we want to build products
that help our users and
prospective users along their investment
journey right
right and so like getting your
information is one thing
how do you do your research is another
thing how do you figure out where to go
there's another thing and so today we do
we do
like a little slice of that uh and
and we want to completely own that
experience so that
we become that trusted source that you
can turn to
when you go out and want to make a
financial decision
and so in your eyes what is the biggest
hurdle
in that in that you know vision in that
journey that you're on
i think at the end of the day there's
two things number one
there's a lot of competition obviously
entering the market and so you have to
build really really good product
and number two is um they're
in the finance space and we're seeing
this right now as well
there is a there's a huge
recency bias that people have oh this
i i did this this went up massively like
this and if i do this again it's going
to go up massively
and that's not the way the the markets
work and so
it's this constant balancing act of
trying to help people understand what's
happening uh
also talking about what's in sort of the
quote-unquote pop culture of finance
like all the gmes of the world um but
also recognizing you know that that's
not everything
and uh and and and having a very healthy
balance between
good principles good coverage but also
covering what people are talking about
right i think i think
honestly you know just uh looking at the
market awards heading and understanding
the growth that it's that it's in it it
sounds like you're in the right market
at the right time it's
you know from from playing around with
the product it looks like it's it's a
it's an amazing product and
hey i as somebody who who needs this
product i i i'm excited to start using
it myself
and and i really want to thank you for
coming here and know how i know that
you're very very busy now i appreciate
it
i have a few questions not about
e-commerce or startups or
or or anything like that i want to talk
about you with
three questions if you have two minutes
yes let's do it let's do it favorite
subject
in middle school or high school
so like i said i i went to go on to
study international relations and
economics and and i always was really
fascinated by
international affairs and i took a sort
of advanced course in school
on politics and i i love that
amazing somebody who's a role model
somebody that inspires you
um i don't i i wouldn't say i have like
one role model per se i what i what i do
is i read up a lot
on entrepreneurs and business people i
love reading
their biographies and autobiographies
and
and then i kind of like draw my own
lessons and takeaways from
anybody from like phil knight with his
uh
nike book to um i recently read a book
about michael bloomberg
uh a better book about the founder of
creative
artists and so i read all these like
biographies and
and i found it fascinating to hear about
their lives and how they went about
building their businesses and i
and i try and take some of the learnings
from that very very cool
and what are three words that you would
use to describe yourself
i think um
number one i would say i i have a
very high level of persistence or grit
whatever you want to call it
uh so i think i continue where a lot of
other people would have given up
um i love to embrace originality
uh so for example when when we build
product
i i really am not a fan of like me too
kind of copycat products that i think
you're starting to see a lot of
um so originality i think is is really
core to what i try to do
um and then i guess the third one
would be i sort of i don't know if
there's a word for it but
sitting at an intersection of like
creative
and analytical um i don't i think i
don't think there's a word
created that's nice i'll take that
exactly
max thank you very very much stay safe
and stay healthy back
best of luck with fenemize and i have a
feeling that you're going to have a few
more ventures down the line so best of
luck with those in advance as well
thank you for coming here i really
appreciate it thank you thank you very
much
take care
you